Jean-Pierre Leclerc s'est penché depuis
18 mois sur un système qui permettrait
de recycler l'eau du bain du lavabo dans
les toilettes l'idée est tellement
simple sur le papier que personne n'y
avait pensé jusqu'à présent et pourtant
la chasse d'eau date de 1778 ce qui me
permet de choisir mon eau soit je la
passe directement en égouts
si elle est pas très propre ou alors je
la passe directement en filtrage elle
contient au moins 30 fois le volume du
chasse d'eau normal pour ce qui est dans
les toilettes est-ce qu'on y met c'est
inutile de mettre une eau potable
donc autant de prendre des eaux recyclés
moins de gaspillage écologique et voilà
et économique